[Musique]
voire trop je vais vous devant djabi le
pop pop pop pop pop
bonsoir les enfants depuis hier notre
gros nounours est vraiment très près ces
oraux que je suis du coup j'oubliais le
principe amène enfin nounours
qu'est ce que tu cherches sous mes pieds
sales yeux elle est venue la petite
souris et le venue repreneur pas preneur
à je commence à comprendre la surmonte
attaché à la cuisine elle est due aux
preneurs
elle est venue la petite souris magique
partout n'a pas trouvé bien sûr j'avais
caché là dedans de pimprenelle sur notre
nuage et j'ai même chatouiller les pieds
du marchand de sable
mais la petite souris est venu entre
nous entre nous
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien c'est fait pour lions
preneur dans laquelle de mes deux pattes
y at il quelque au chaud et voilà
j'suis vraiment good as montbronn nous
vidons mais c'est une vraie bien qu'un
bruit
je l'aimais km qui relie c'est une
excellente idée
[Musique]
ces familles hors lada nous la petite
souris la garder et maintenant les
enfants
vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
maintenant il faut se laver les dents
pour faire plaisir à la petite souris
qui est venu et après vous irez où les
laïcs au lit
[Musique]
produits le grand le plus beau
au lit ou les boules
oui oui je vous le litre ou les couilles
ce soit figé on fait du bruit c'est le
roulis bulli
[Musique]
on lit tous les hommes oui oui au lit
le net ou bien sauf
nous on vous dit hall nonoche le dis on
obéit
on va au lit au lit
[Musique]
amis au nord cela dit
ou l'hydraulique ou lit au lit coulisses
au lit
oui oui nounours vous
non vous vous dit on lit au lit au lit
est bonne mais oui bonne nuit au lit
bonne nuit les rangs les petits bonne
nuit les grands les petits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais oui nounours a dit olli au lit
bonne nuit
bobo
[Musique]
oh